pour l'après midi vous avez bien
j'imagine en vous disant que j'étais
policier vous attendait peut-être avoir
un homme en uniforme donc l'uniforme
fait pas l'âme donc écoutez je suis né
il ya quelques années sur une petite île
qui s'appelle l'île de la gonâve en
haïti en 1990 au départ de jean claude
duvalier l'instabilité qui avait dans le
pays lors que mon père m'a fait un
milliard au québec
donc pour poursuivre les études j'ai
étudié à saint-hyacinthe et je suis venu
à montréal pour terminer mes études j'ai
fait un baccalauréat spécialisé en
sociologie
malheureusement j'ai pas réussi à
travailler dans mon domaine mais de fil
en aiguille mon rêve était toujours de
pouvoir aider les autres
donc j'ai travaillé pour service
correctionnel du canada et au service
correctionnel du canada je me suis rendu
compte que j'étais à la fin du processus
donc les gens avec qui je travaillais là
et pénitenciers fédéraux
c'est des gens qui avaient été sans
penser et qui se retrouvaient là et moi
toute ma vie je m'étais toujours dit que
j'aimerais ça travailler soit avec les
jeunes mais surtout d'aider les gens les
autres parce que la petite ville parce
que je suis né en haïti j'ai été élevé
en communauté donc chaque agent avait la
responsabilité et se sentait obligé de
me transmettre son savoir les bonnes
mains les bonnes façons de faire mais
surtout pour m e repris marc délia pas
juste mais parra qui pourrait me
recommander
donc je suis parti de là avec ce bagage
là qui aujourd'hui il ya quelques années
on avait au québec mais aujourd'hui que
c'est perdu
aujourd'hui je travaille comme policier
est très souvent je me promenais dans la
rue il va avoir une voiture avec un
système d'alarmé qui m'appartient une
fois que le simple dalle en parle
vous savez qu est ce que les gens font
ils vont furent vous allez dans un pack
vous allez trouver des jeunes en train
de frapper un aux jeunes et les parents
vont se tourner la tête
on se déresponsabilise on n'ose même
plus dire aux jeunes est fait pour ça le
comportement l'attitude cutter c'est pas
acceptable dans notre société
donc moi ce que vous invite aujourd'hui
c'est notre capacité à faire la
différence
il ya personne personnes dans le monde
qui n'est pas capable de faire la
différence à moyens à court ou à long t
on a tous le pouvoir de faire la
différence et puis parvenu jeudi à dire
est une cause qui vous passionne dont
nous avons les équipes ont apporté une
contribution bénéfique quand j'ai
commencé à travailler à casser saint
michel
il y avait une problématique au métro
saint michel les jeunes après l'école se
retrouver au micro et les jeunes avaient
une discussion puis les jeunes par
l'effort mais il y avait des gens âgés
aussi qu'ils se trouvaient dans le métro
et ces gens là ils vivaient de la
sécurité parce que quand il est arrivé
il ya 40 50 60 jeunes et les personnes
âgées étaient comme méfiant un peu et on
a dit c'est de faire une opération
policière
la prévention parle avec les jeunes
faisait pas loin et un règlement de la
stm qui interdit de flâner dans le métro
donc toutes les excuses comme si bon il
fallait se débarrasser la jeunesse alors
de fil à aiguille on nous a imposé une
opération policière ou ce qu'une bonne
journée à présent vous observez les
jeunes on a fermé les ports on a émis
des conseils des fractions de 118
dollars à chaque jeune qui se trouvaient
dans le métro pouvez pas vous imaginer
il ya des jeunes qui pleurait et je me
suis un jeune gay vraiment aimé écoute
ici mon père homme tué jeudi voyant non
oui tu peux pas arriver chez moi avec un
constat de 118 dollars
le deuxième est pourquoi que telle on
vous a versé en fait rien de mal qu'est
ce qu'on fait de mal on n'a pas
d'alternative on n'a pas la loi pour se
retrouver après l'école il dit tout ce
qu'on fait je prends les inviter chez
moi c'est trop petit et il n'y a pas
d'autres endroits
et là j'ai pris la décision je me suis
dit écoute je veux essayer de vous
trouver un endroit où si après l'école
pourrait venir profiter blaguer et de
fil en aiguille j'ai décidé de parler à
tous les intervenants du milieu pour
trouver un emploi et à l'écho l'usep et
puis il y avait un local abandonné il y
avait même des ira donc c'est le local
comme à donner du tout ce que j'ai fait
le ménage
j'ai mis des produits et j'ai parti le
club de boxe l'espoir mais quand j'ai
porté le club de boxe l'espoir
le spvm ne voulait pas nécessairement
que j'apprenne aux jeunes à se battre
c'était ça la vision
vous allez apprendre aux jeunes
défavorisés des gangs de rue à ce bal
puis vont se retourner contre nous
nelson mandela disait aucun de nous en
agissant seul ne peut atteindre le
succès évidemment j'avais beau avoir
cette idée là c'était impossible pour
moi d'y arriver deux seuls ce que j'ai
fait j'ai écrit une demande de
subvention auprès de la ville de
montréal pour leur dire que je voulais
avoir un club de boxe pour aider les
jeunes et on me dit non à peu près la
même chose qu'elle est que le spvm c'est
pas vrai que vous allez apprendre aux
gangs de rue à se battre bon je me suis
dit qu il ya toujours moyen de moyenner
dans la vie c'est pour être convaincant
il faut être convaincu
j'étais convaincu de ce que j'allais
faire c'était bien alors je suis
retourné à l'université et parlait que
des ennemis et je la gtl bibliothèque et
là l'idée m'est venue de reformuler made
man ville de montréal j'avais un projet
qui s'appelait mieux grandir par le
sport merveilleux j'ai hérité de 4000
dollars c'est beaucoup
avec 4000 $ j'ai acheté des corps des
cadets des cordes et pas depuis mon
local était prêt j'ai commencé à donner
des coups mais dès qu abandonner les
causes et est suivi une formation par la
fédération de boxe olympique du québec
et là moi je donne l écho aux jeunes
mais pas parce que je donnerais l'écho
oui j'en ai un emploi à temps plein je
les donner quand cette et faisant son
montant j'avais un oral les journées que
j'avais deux eaux je pourrais donner des
cours assurés de soi non de nuit non
dans mes congés oui et là j'avais des
enfants je ne me séparais alors nez
mais les enfants sont le lieu et ça m'a
permis de créer un lien parce qu'au
début les jeunes étaient un peu méfiant
parce qu'il disait ça se peut pas ça se
paie pas un policier que veut nous aider
mais non écoute il doit tendre de korver
il veut savoir ce qu'on fait c'était un
peu mal vu mais avec la présence de mes
enfants y ont fini par comprendre ce que
je voulais faire c'était bien donc je me
suis
10 mon défi personnel à moi c'est de
combattre l'exclusion sociale chez les
jeunes des quartiers défavorisés et
pourquoi chez les jeunes défavorisés
parce que le destin a voulu que je
travaille dans le quartier saint michel
et le quartier saint michel n'est pas
qu'il faut pas vous imaginer quand j'ai
commencé l'an 2000 droit à chaque fois
qu'il se passait quelque chose de
négatif ou centre-ville les médias
arriver well et gagne 2 rue de saint
michel ont tiré au centre ville ok parce
que finalement la fusillade s'est gouré
rivière des prairies ou stand de laval
mais les jeunes du casier était vraiment
stigmatiser on avait vraiment sort on
dit toujours le saint michel c'est le
berceau des bleus donc le suis dit non
je vais essayer de faire autre chose
on va essayer de leur montrer qu à
saint-michel ya autre chose à l'école
louis-joseph-papineau bruny surin était
à l'école joseph papineau de gagner une
médaille olympique
yvan delorme a été à l'école joseph
papineau qui est devenir directeur du
service de police de la ville de
montréal il ya bien bien d'autres et
j'ai pris ce modèle-là et c'est ça que
je dis aux jeunes c'est pas vrai ton
avenir il ya personne n'y a personne au
monde qui peut dire que tu peux pas
devenir quelqu'un on a tous un potentiel
il faut croire en toi et d'aller
chercher les et qui donc c'est pas vrai
comme tout seul non des fois c'est
difficile mais avec une équipe aller
chercher les gens on est capable d'y
arriver
et quand je parle de permettre de rêver
c'est que éric lucas a été champion du
monde il m'a envoyé les billets pour
ramener des mes jeunes voire gala de
boxe et pendant qu'on était assez dans
la salle puis un gel utilisé aura acquis
qu'ils sont chanceux qui commence et qui
sont chanceux dirigeants sont sous leur
aile on voit leurs photos puis le comme
gros joueurs cadres en visant les gens
les applaudir zinc ça m'arrivera jamais
j'avais un jeune de 15 ans qui se
permettaient même pas de rêver je
trouvais ça j'ai pas de mots j'ai eu
tellement le thème de noël qui ne rêve
pas il n'y a pas d'âge pour rêver tout
le monde rêve et là j'avais un jeune de
15 qui va arrêter de rêver
et ça ça m'a traumatisé charvet à la
maison je me suis dit faut faire quelque
chose pour faire quelque chose
j'ai appelé quelques amis et on m'a
présenté à quelques à la tohu
l'atelier une des plus belles salles au
québec
et l'on me dit le jcj expliqué jeudi
côtière ses skis mais dernièrement voici
ce qui m'est arrivé est là tôt ils me
disent on va fermer le rêve de sa vie
at-on jeunes et la tohu m'ont fait
gratuitement d'organiser mon gala de
boxe dans les lieux de la tenue et le
jeune vous aurait dû voir ses yeux le
soir du gala en sortant et regarder les
gens qui pleuraient et là je lui dis à
l'oreille
mon garçon qui doit pouvoir rêver il
faut se permettre de rêver et c'est ce
que je vous inciter à faire quand vous
savez un jeune qui est un rêve peut-être
pas tout seul mais en équipe on est
capable d'y arriver mais à travers tour
ça l'activité sportive
l'activité pour ce sportif c'est mon
levier pour la persévérance scolaire
parce que chaque jeune qui fréquentent
mon club de boxe il doit fréquenter une
équipe une institution scolaire
on peut devenir champion du monde mais
on n'est pas champions du monde on vit
oui on sait combien il postait vie
nécessairement aller en devenant un
athlète olympique ce qui nous permet
d'évoluer dans la société
puis de prendre leur place si
l'éducation est la seule façon d'avoir
une éducation c'est de persévérer à
l'école donc tous les jeunes qui
fréquentent mon club de boxe
ils peuvent continuer à fréquenter le
club de boxe tâte aussi en plaques qui
vont à l'école et quand déjà l'art est
d'aller à l'école
jeudi paul on ne peut pas ce que je dis
aux jeunes je suis dans le laps de temps
six mois pour reprendre la main qu'est
ce que ça prend on va travailler
ensemble c'est comme nos enfants la
journée que vos enfants ne va pas à
l'école vous dites pourrait prendre la
porte nord de la maison
non on s'assoit avec nos enfants
puis on essaye de voir c'est quoi le
bien-être qu'est ce que on peut faire
pour les pour les jeunes c'est la même
chose que je fais avec les jeunes
est ce que tout ça je pourrais y arriver
non il ya quelques temps j'ai eu des
problèmes j'ai perdu mon local de boxe
c'était pénible pour moi mais aussi pour
mes jeunes et c'est là que j'arrive avec
la complémentarité des ressources il ya
quelqu'un dans la salle
merci isabelle vous avez choisi écoute
je vais me battre avec toi qui on va
trouver une place j'ai le plaisir
aujourd'hui de vous annoncer le mois
prochain je serai au collège maisonneuve
donc la compagnie la complémentarité des
ressources parce qu'aujourd'hui dans le
milieu communautaire
c'est pas vrai qu'un jeune une ressource
peut tout donner aux jeunes c'est
impossible
ce qu'on a besoin c'est nécessairement
pas se battre pour les mêmes budgets
parce que les budgets sont limités mais
au moins c'est d'aller chercher d'autres
sources de faire une table de
concertation
moi ce que j'offre aux jeunes s'est
jamais suffisant monsieur des ateliers
des ateliers avec des infirmières qui
vient leur part les télésites et est ce
qu'ils veulent en parler les méfaits des
commotions cérébrales
j'ai aussi des médecins qui veulent en
parler j'ai des athlètes olympiques qui
va leur parler donc des modèles positifs
mais en même temps qui aide le jeune à
s'améliorer
et ça c'est une responsabilité partagée
de tous vers un but ultime l'intégration
du jeune sur le marché du travail et sa
participation à donner au suivant
parce que le jeune ait une voix qui va
intégrer le marché du travail
ils vont être acté il va faire son
apport dans la société et c'est sûr
qu'on veut aujourd'hui on est là c'est
puis ont travaillé dans diverses sphères
la société mais demain on a besoin d'une
relève est là relève c'est la jeunesse
si on s'en occupe pas qu'ils vont s'en
occuper et même le gel les plus
criminalisés saisie mais non ça se dit
pas le jeune le plus criminalisés non un
jeune qui a fait des erreurs c'est j'en
ai connu des jeunes qui ont fait des
erreurs dans mon métier malheureusement
un langage à peu coloré on va les
appeler été des bandits ou quoi que ce
soit moi je les appelle encore des
jeunes pour la même chose que je vous
disais tantôt quand nos enfants font des
erreurs on l'aimé pas là pas la même
chose pour les jeunes qu'on côtoie un
jeune peut faire une erreur de 0 3 0
mais on a toujours la possibilité de
l'aider
à avancer dans la vie quelques il ya
peut-être 40 50 ans aperçu un criminel
notoire c'est pas vrai qu'on va me dire
un jeune qui a 15 16 17 ans c'est un
criminel notoire pour tous il ya
toujours moyen de faire quelque chose et
ce jeune le cas on l'aide plus tard
qu'est ce qui va faire il va donner au
suivant
comment qu'on fait pour donner au
suivant l'implication bénévole
j'ai une question pour vous vous avez 5
secondes pour me répondre
il ya combien d'heures dans une semaine
il ya 168 ans dans une semaine
dans le monde occidental on travaille en
moyenne 40 heures par semaine
si le 128 heures si on veut on est tous
capables de faire peut-être un deux
heures trois ans à 4 heures de bénévolat
il ya des gens qui vont dire j'ai pas
l'aptitude le bénévolat c'est pas pour
moi il ya des employeurs ce que j'incite
les employés enfants c'est quoi au
potentiel des jeunes sans expérience
lors des embauches tous dans la salle
avec les diplômes que vous avez un jour
que quelqu'un qui a décidé de vous
donner votre chance mais ça c'est se
donner au suivant
si croire au potentiel des jeunes y en a
d'autres qui vont me dire je prends un
employeur je porte un nom plus je vous
invite à faire des dons pas des milliers
de dollars des fois juste 20 40 ou 50
dollars ça peut faire une différence
et tout ça qu'est-ce que ça m'a emmené à
faire ça m'a mené avant une expérience
un peu à l'international en 2010 lorsque
le tremblement terre en haïti
le spvm et la ville de montréal me
délégués pour faire partie de
l'opération coup de main à les aider les
gens sur le terrain comment j'ai appelé
les gens que je connais fédération les
meilleurs canado-haïtiens d'avoir des
médecins gratuit j'ai appelé un jeune
qui était commissaire bord pour les bras
qui travaille pour la csdm il est venu
avec mon outil parrainé une école pour
la construction pour la reconstruction
en 2011
j'étais invité comme conférencier
séminaire sur la sécurité publique
canada france à paris pourquoi pour
aller parler un peu qu'est ce qu'on fait
nous ici à montréal
la proche de la police
me notaire est engagé dans sa communauté
je reviens à paris dernièrement la
vision nouvelle
on a beaucoup parlé de saint denis
district 93 j'étais à paris pendant
quatre heures district 93 à aucun moment
j'ai vu un policier
pourquoi l'approché différents on dit
que le secteur est problématique et la
police n'y va pas à montréal on fait
l'inversé quand secteurs problématiques
on y va un paquet problématique on fait
des activités avec la police on est là
on est présent et on veut redonner le
secteur à la population
ses seules approches et des fois les
gens me disent mais comment qu'on sait
que ça fonctionne j'ai pas de données
tanger pour dire comment ça fonctionne
ce que je peux vous dire ce que j'ai
c'est surtout les remerciements c'est
surtout des lettres des jeunes qui
viennent qui m'écrivent et qui me disent
comment j'ai pu influencer leur vie
nelson mandela disait il ne peut y avoir
plus vives révélations de l'âme d'une
société que la manière dont elle traite
ses enfants aujourd'hui ce que je vous
dirai si vous voulez un monde meilleur
traiter chacun des enfants que vous
allez croiser sur votre chemin
comme vous aimeriez qu'on traite un de
vos enfants et vous ne serez jamais dans
l'erreur tendez la main à la jeunesse
j'ai une jeune qui fréquentait le club
dernièrement qui m'a écrit ça et cette
fille là elle m'appelle pas pas mes
enfants l'appellent comme leur soeur
parce que elle fait partie intégrante de
ma famille j'allais une autre qui m'a
écrit ça pourquoi parce que j'ai
toujours cru à cette jeunesse là et le
dernier par point je les réussis à peu
près un mois ça m'a mis les larmes aux
yeux je sais pas pourquoi peut-être un
peu fatigué mais c'est que c'est
tellement ça fait tellement du bien
parce que c'est difficile de quantifier
la prévention la prévention peut
fonctionner aujourd'hui mais des fois
c'est à long terme
donc on va voir des résultats dans cinq
ans dans 10
ou dans 20 ans mais ce que je veux vous
dire à chacun et chacune d'entre vous
dans la salle aujourd'hui et aux gens
qui regardent je vous le dis l'avenir
c'est la jeunesse
si vous investissez à la jeunesse pour
leur donner une chance
c'est impossible que le monde de demain
ne soit pas meilleur
merci et bonne